what's happening there reject nation
greg here and john here and now that we
are back in a normal flow these sh these
will be going back to a regular schedule
starting next week we just have to get
back into flow when strong got back in
the office the office that's what we
call this room this bedroom
hey leave a like i like that
and so would you full length watch
alongs we've seen with the time code for
gravity falls at our patreon page become
a super eject today by checking out all
the content we've got offer over there
lastly the boys at prepper handsome
devils helping us edit these down thanks
helping us catch up let's do it
[Music]
i am the master of attic stuff mini golf
from the mighty swiss south to the
badlands of dipper's old laundry where
man fears to shred all right let a pro
on the field or floor whatever
ooh
ah my head it hit me right in the head
yes stan shot is that legal
the judges say it's out of bounds you're
out of bounds
start whacking each other my friends are
coming to me wait what
oh no no no no sleeping bags
calling all boys pre-teen edition
dream phone
no
no girls son of a [ __ ]
no
no
okay so how much do you like boys so
much boys make me think about kissing
candy oh my god
crazy tonight
[Laughter]
mabel do you think you could do this
somewhere else you're laughing at
frequencies only dogs should hear you
know what your brother needs huh a
makeover
do it nice
hey seuss can i sleep in your break room
tonight of course dude
i just got to make your body go like a
video game puzzle block
the trick is to hold perfectly still
oh wait wait ow
ah sleeping under the stars not bad
that is a terrible idea yep
[Applause]
this is still better
[Laughter]
ah what happened last night ah hangover
i don't know what i was kissing in there
but i have no regrets candy falls down
now live your best life hey brother you
want any of this leftover pizza it's got
glitter on it
you've totally wrecked our room and oh
oh no our mini golf course
yeah grinder sure loves breaking things
mabel we need to lay down some ground
rules if we're gonna be living in this
room together first of all no sleepovers
what what whoa
then you can't keep me up every night
with your summer reading how does
reading keep you up
oh
interesting
but
[Laughter]
the sibling brother is nice view me out
one more time
okay that's it that's the final straw
maybe we shouldn't share a room anymore
oh maybe we shouldn't then we need to
talk to grunkle stan about moving rooms
yeah he's a reasonable guy oh no uncle
stan we want different rooms what do you
think there's some kind of secret hidden
room in the shack
dudes i found some kind of secret hidden
room in the shack
[Applause]
[Music]
classy july 4th
experiment 78.
grunkle stan what is this place i don't
know just another room i got to clean up
now
i guess i'll give it to whichever one of
you i like more
uh-oh looks like my shoe's untied
that's abusive i don't know dudes this
room gives me major creepo vibes you
know the attic is a pretty good space
maybe you two should appreciate what you
got don't try and teach us a lesson now
maybe there's nothing creepy going on in
this room
cool shot uncle stan we're not going to
suck up to you just to get the new room
yeah we are ten sucker points for mabel
i mean uh yeah we are
trying too hard minus 15 sucker points
man that's refreshing 10 sucker points
for this lemonade thank you stan
10 more for politeness
are you even keeping tally all these
chores will be worth it when i get this
room shag carpeting come on
oh no i say i'm gonna win this room
somehow and when i do i'll finally have
my own space and we'll never have to
share anything ever again
what the hell is going on oh no
dipper why are you wearing my clothes
face am i in your body am i in your body
[Music]
this isn't happening this doesn't happen
you're oh and sibling
your own sibling no great just what we
need more gravity falls weirdness this
is stupid sharing a room was bad enough
now we're sharing bodies don't get naked
experiment 78
electron carpet this carpet must build
up a static charge so powerful it can
swap mines it was the static electricity
maybe we could use it to switch back
if i was you i would totally lose the
contest and if i was you which i am i
could sabotage myself then mabel would
lose all her points and the room would
go to dipper wait what oh stan
i've always hated you
see who he gives the room to now no wait
go
tie your shoes appreciate the animators
change their body language a lot you'll
love this a sandwich made out of rocks
candy rocks
regular rocks
don't do it but i'll be giving your
brother this key
i mean
hey uncle's dad your face looks like a
butt what breaking stuff is so much fun
i am dipper and i stink
ugh
wait are you going to dark mabel point
what do you mean we should lose island's
plane
stand
bottles yes
you got a good bro you got no worries i
mean nobody thinks it's cute when i lie
naked on the living room floor i wish i
could be a pig
yes go forth
is that a corn cob i spy
i got a little legs
oh no
it's about the same
[Music]
gross oh
hey uh could i talk to my um
sister for a sec this is a sleepover
buddy no boys allowed
oh no
guys i'm not really in a sleepover mood
right now my mom's age inappropriate
romance novels aren't going to read
themselves
wolfman bear chess yeah
you're at that creepy age where you spy
on girls huh guess it's time you and me
had a man-to-man talk about the birds
and the bees you know
oh no
what the hell is sweaty
it all begins with this little fella the
pituitary gland he may be little but he
has big plans
[Laughter]
oh no
[Laughter]
a mud puddle
do i dare live out the cliche
oh no
i'm a man trapped in a pig's body that's
what they all say
[Music]
a bearded witch chasing a talk
and now you know where babies come from
goodbye childhood oh
shut up old man
i love it you know i've made up my mind
the room belongs to you dipper you can't
you have to give it to mabel shh you had
me at shut up old man
[Music]
now for the 38 sequels
[Music]
i'm gonna make you into bacon oh that
sounds pretty good
wait i mean
[Laughter]
stan gave you the room
yes all right
well let's switch bodies then and i can
start moving in wait a minute you can't
have the room if you could never get in
hey oh
open the door dipper i mean mabel
i'd get confused myself who wants to
give my brother a makeover
look time's a tough economy or something
etc basically i have to cut your pay
[Laughter]
is this some sort of negotiating tactic
cause it's not gonna work
i was lying i'll give you a raise just
never do that again
can you help me i'm looking for
directions
oh
no
oh you'll show me the way such a
gentleman oh my god
[Music]
we're gonna make you so hot wait no stop
now
good job ladies now let me just add one
oh no
[Music]
oh but they're all on the carpet i'm a
genius
yeah all right mabel the room is mine
wait hold on here what just happened ugh
i barely understand it oh it worked you
can switch bodies or whatever
oh no
[Applause]
oh come on
i am a boy now what's up bro let's grow
some monster shoes let's go with some
mustangs
stop fighting
oh no
then again i like having muscles for
once everybody look swap back in three
two one
i wanna deep fry oh
no
you guys are stressing me out i guess
i'm a pig now so that's a thing
i'm i'm i'm this body's not that
different from my old one we've got some
reports of excessive giggling
oh no didn't say anything about this
what's happening
i am a police officer now
let's go bust some perps candy give me
that key maybe
what is going on
everything was fine until you started
bringing your friends around every night
i mean hanging out with you this
summer's been fun but
now you're always with candy and grenda
and i'm
like just left behind
oh
what a loser uh yeah exactly
sorry buddy
you're probably feeling awkward and
sweaty huh
yeah
how'd you know it's a reproductive book
that stan showed
you got a lot to learn dipper looks like
everyone's back to normal oh except for
seuss who may be a pig permanently
oh no i trained back
hey i've been thinking and the answer is
yes i will marry you wait i don't
remember anything about
you lucky pig you oh my
ah
finally my own room
good night mabel
oh
buddy
good night dipper
hey um do you want to have a sleepover
yeah
so what are we gonna do with that new
room
i gave it to seuss to replace that
horrible break room he has i just don't
think i can do this anymore you just
seem so different
oh
zeus i'm playing a little bit of ketchup
here i was in a pig's body for most of
the day
can we kiss again is that an option
he made it sound like he did it with a
pig
yeah which you know
it wouldn't be unimaginable either
story's believable
[Laughter]
please an episode on a good solid build
a nice crescendo
i feel like we've done a lot of talking
this season about the differences
between the episodes that really i feel
like we've been in a good streak for a
while now that really kind of pick a
story and then really dive into all the
different ways that that could go and i
liked yeah the the very relatable
probably for anybody who at least has a
sibling that they ever shared a room
with
which i actually don't have that
experience i never shared a room with my
sibling except in like you know hotel
scenarios but
yeah you know that's i gotta imagine a
little tough moment in life where you
realize you're getting older you want to
have your friends in
and uh yeah maybe it's time to move on
to at least you know having a different
dynamic at home and that's a little bit
of a bittersweet thing
and then all the hijinks that ensue with
the body swapping you know it was fun
because yeah it's like you know i feel
like
they could have just stopped at just
having it be oh they're trying to
sabotage each other but you to take it
that
extra step further of having just
everybody by the end all the friends the
cops mr mcgucket it was actually kind of
tense in a whimsical sort of way i was
like oh this is gonna this is a mess
and all the damage that could be done in
you know whimsical fashions and whatnot
but uh yeah i thought they did a really
nice job of actually
you know
making me tense while also being very
much fun and i'm a sucker
for that trope where uh you know
somebody tells off somebody in a
position of authority and power
only for that person and then turn
around and go you know what we need
initiative like that around here i've
been waiting for you to stand up to me
you got the whatever thing that you want
that's always a a joke that works quite
nicely for me um and yeah you know
expanding on the mystery shack too i
feel like even though this doesn't tie
in to whatever grunkle stan knows or has
going on that nobody else knows about
it's still like fun to find a secret
room in the shack give more personality
to the setting itself overall i thought
this was a very fun episode what did you
think yeah it was a great one it was
great
well they could have pushed the envelope
a little bit more i think could have
gone a little bit more gritty
you know this is this would be a really
gross subject this could be something
that can be really disturbing and
horrific if you think about it
like
dipper's going through puberty yep
and so he needs his own room i just
think it's appropriate for him to have
his own private space when you're a 12
year old boy going through for 12 13 how
early is going through puberty you need
to have your own space for reasons that
i'm sure you could fill in the blank
because he ain't shooting bla you're
filling the blank
for why he would need to be going
through puberty right hence why he's
getting the learning lesson there i'm
not trying to be
vulgar i'm not trying to be a reverend
it's a fact objectively speaking
i think it's more appropriate if they
live in separate rooms
however you could have made some really
disgusting horror scenarios
out of it it could have been really
psychologically conflicting for them can
you imagine what it would be like to
switch bodies with your own sibling
and then you like have to take a shower
and then you're in the mirror looking at
your naked sibling
in your own body
and then some
disgusting stuff starts to happen and
i'm
but you could do some gross stuff this
is more tense than the episode it's just
saying is he good the idea is really
icky
tis
[ __ ] like freaky friday freaks me out
your own mom
that's that's gross
yeah i understand it's a gross concept
this is really gross
so without it
veering away from the fact that this is
a disney show
i think it did a great job it was really
uncomfortable i didn't actually see the
learning lesson coming that was a nice
surprise a lot of the time
the theme or the message whatever it is
they're trying to convey amongst his
characters this theme of like growing up
i did not see that coming up when they
were when they were about to like really
duke it out with over the key and then
the truth was revealed that they didn't
really want to live separately
and that dipper ultimately was just
feeling alone he was feeling left behind
because i think is a very relatable
feeling i i completely get it uh you
know even like having a brother who's
six years older
and
growing up i didn't like we sometimes
shared the same room there was a period
where we did
it wasn't like home my room my brother
however i think we all have our own
feeling of you know when you're
if you're amongst a friend group and you
feel left behind or something like that
and you just don't know how to quite
express that i think that's something
the show captures pretty well is
that
that lack of being able to truly
communicate and instead you act out in
different ways i think is something the
show captures about i mean adults do it
however i think we capture that with the
youth i think they have a really good
grip on because i i didn't anticipate
that being the
the ultimate outcome actually yeah and
um yeah all those hijinks with uncle
stan putting them through the ringer on
how to kiss ass to him
i thought was really amusing it was a
really fun one
and uh this might be my favorite little
bit that they've done
with
oh god toy blanket on his name right now
with zeus this might be my favorite bit
they've done with seuss
i like that he got the girl in the end
and she fell in love with the pig
instead yeah
yeah that was a really funny bit
well yeah
yeah the implication of just like what i
i almost would have loved to have seen
like it's it's better that we don't but
it does make you go man i wish i could
see what what the rest of her following
him around town must have looked like
and yeah like i too appreciate that by
the end of the episode you have it be
that even though they reach that
conclusion they still go through with it
and they still go to their separate
rooms and they still kind of take this
next
sort of life step
and there is a bitter sweetness after
the resolve like the resolve is kind of
rewarding and then the actual wrap-up of
the episode is a little bit like oh you
know we're growing up a little bit
and i feel like that lends itself to
just the sort of like you know it's
we're up here for the summer it's a new
thing you know we're staying with our
uncle like it kind of goes back to
compliment just the the general setup of
the show itself
and uh yeah grunkle stan's got good
taste in tv
baby fights
that show picked up man spin-off yeah
and two i mean they it's weird like they
don't go full-on into it but they do at
least acknowledge the puberty thing in a
pretty amusing way with the sweaty book
i thought that was that was kind of fun
yeah my parents never had a sex talk
with me i never had anything like that
with them
not much i had the internet to teach
i had the super mario instructional sex
dead
all right guys well another great
episode of gravity falls really fun and
inventive and uh yeah this concept
generally the switching bodies
consciousness thing always uh i think
it's a really gross subject
it's really icky to me while you're
invading someone's body yet i don't i've
never really seen something where they
go all out on just how
messed up this could be me and john
malkovich is a pretty good one on that
actually i think being john malkovich
does a pretty great job on that
but whenever they do with like family
they always keep it like funny
which i'd expect gravity falls to keep
it as i'd be surprised that they went
horror
that was sarcasm at the beginning guys
but you must someone wants to write
their like disgusting gross
tormented version
of it exploring sexuality i think that
would be a really cool freaky friday i
think that'd be a really really just
like messed up but
disturbing horror film you can make and
i'm surprised no one's uh maybe they
have it i just haven't come across it
maybe no one's done it that good just
yet yeah we need to see it man that
would be freaking awesome yeah
all right gang cool in the game thank
you for being here thanks for watching
with us let's uh end this with a paper
fox if there's anyone at the patreon who
i would want to give me a makeover it's
you i think you would be out of the box
with your decisions no doubt would i
look like a pretty pretty person but i
feel like you would get creative you
would probably bring in costume choices
set decorations by the end i'll be in my
own living tableau all authored by your
design because you got a good hip kind
of sensibility about you and every time
i see you pop up in the comments here on
patreon you always got a unique take and
i like unique things and i want to look
unique so fox we gotta set this up and i
will pay you
thousands of dollars to make me pretty
so uh that's what we gotta do next love
you hope you're doing well happy spring
it's just become the spring time and i
hope life is flourishing for you
new growth abounding and we'll catch you
next month much love
be well be well
[Music]